Take around fat and carbon take around and then we can throw all that garbage
into a Meta analysis.
And the one thing I'm pretty confident as they did a poor job because the one
study I looked up,
the one with the biggest effect,
they mistook kilojoules for kilocalories.
So they reported that 400 kilocalories decrease in energy expenditure on the low
fat diet one was a 400 kilo joule,
which is,
what's that factor?
You know,
these numbers,
uh,
0.8 0.18 or something.
Several of the other studies where Jim Hill Studies,
we've talked about Jim Hill,
the biggest studies where Jim Hill and the way we approached it,
the not for profit.
Let's say.
You've got to understand what the question is and you've got to design an
experiment to get the right answer.
So when Stephen Dismiss this
Harvard three names for him now deference to follow Dna,
this DNA,
right?
Dr Ganek stepped up named Stephanie.
It's really easy to have fun.
I can do it,
do it.
I just don't get names.
Um,
my name's Joe.
I Gary that I know.
I do the um,
Stephan,
uh,
ultimately rejected this study about a $12 million study that was done at
Harvard based on Kevin Hall.
So these are two names.
It's about three people out there who are convinced that everything people like
me are saying is wrong or not everything but most of it.
And they keep coming up over and over again and they would.
So Kevin Hall claims that he has refuted the carbohydrate insulin model in his
studies.
So I want to study comes out supporting it.
He works to find out why that studies wrong.
We all did the same thing.
I did the same thing right here with the coolness study explaining why I don't
find that meaningful.
But anyway,
that's the thing.
The goal was to do the right study cause ultimately you got to remember what's
on the line here.
We have obesity and diabetes epidemics.
I mean tragic shit is going on out there.
I mean people,
you know these are ruining lives.
There are overwhelming the healthcare system.
And the argument I made is that for the past 50 years,
basically people,
I've thought a lot like Stephanie is thinking now doctor g and a and that there
appears to be another story that could be true and what we have to do is find
out if it is true because people are dying now and out
their stuff.
Okay.
Um,
the first thing I want to say is that this alternative explanation that Gary is
talking about has already been investigated intensively including studies that
were funded by his own organization.
Nusi two out of the three studies that have been published on that,
we're clear reputations of the hypothesis and no,
no,
no.
I'm gone responded here.
No,
no.
I know you've got to represent the studies.
Correct.
Gary,
I representing them according to your beliefs is not representing them
correctly.
Okay.
Now I've noticed a remarkable correlation between studies undermining your
beliefs and you thinking those studies are garbage and we should talk about uh,
Jim Hill and his studies a little bit because you know,
to me just saying,
this guy has a conflict of interest and then insinuating that that makes the
study bad if you can't actually find a problem with the study itself.
These were very rigorous studies.
If you cannot point out specific problem with the study,
it was designed with an assumption.
It was designed based on the assumption it was supposed,
it wasn't design how Gary wanted it to be designed.
If you cannot find a problem with that study,
then you can't just dismiss it by making these insinuations that the person had
a conflict of interest.
Okay.
I now into the problem though.
That's great.
Gary now [inaudible] on it at the time.
All right.
You're going to be able to respond in a moment.
Now the Cuna,
I think we should really get back to this issue,
this nonindustrial culture because the primary basis for Gary's book,
the case against sugar,
the primary observation that underlies Gary's belief on this is this
observational correlational thing that cultures,
when sugar gets into these cultures,
they become that and that is the common thread and in obesity and so what I'm
doing is I'm pointing out a culture where sugar came in and it did not make them
fat and that's one of three cultures.
I haven't even looked that hard.
Okay.
These are just three cultures that I came across is probably a bunch more that
are eating high levels of sugar,
but they're eight and are not welcome them into our hobbies.
And I think,
and again,
Joe explanation is right on point.
There's a lot of other things going on in these cultures and it's more
complicated than just sugar.
That's exactly my point.
Now I want to talk about the Cuban economic crisis.
This is reference number 22 from a 1989 through 1995 the Cuban economy collapsed
and the price of food went way up.
The price of gasoline went way up,
and so people started focusing on these really cheap foods.
Cuba was a major sugar producer at the time.
I don't know if they still are,
and so the intake of sugar went way up and take a refined carbohydrate,
went way up the Diet became a 77% carbohydrate,
primarily white rice and sugar,
28% sugar of their total calorie intake.
So that's like double what Americans eat.
Now their calorie intake went down and because of the lack of gasoline,
people got really physically active because they had to walk everywhere.
So now again,
if this is,
this is a situation where we can test Gary's hypothesis.
If Gary is right and calories don't matter,
only refined carbohydrate and sugar matter,
obesity should have gone through the roof in this population over that period of
time.
What you actually see is that the prevalence of obesity declined by half.
So there was a 50% decline.
It went from 14% to 7% over the period of this increase in sugar intake,
increase in refined carbohydrate intake.
And you might think,
well these people are just starving like crazy.
And that's why obesity rate went down.
Well,
we actually have evidence on the rate of underweight as well.
And so we can check on that.
The rate of underweight increased only slightly went from 8% to 10%.
And so we know these people weren't just totally starving.
Um,
and what happened then was as the Diet rebounded,
as the economy rebounded in the diet rebounded and their diets shifted away from
these refined carbohydrates and sugar and back to the normal diet that was
higher in,
uh,
in fats and lower in carbohydrate,
lower in sugar,
the obesity rate went right back up as soon as they went back to their normal
diet.
And so I find this,
cause there were,
there were not walking as much.
Yeah,
I was the exercise and also just their diet became richer again.
I mean,
if you're eating a diet that's a very poor diet,
eating white rice and sugar,
I mean it,
it's not like if that's most of what if you're sitting there and on your plate
is a white rice and sugar,
you're not going to be eating a ton of that and getting fat as opposed to eating
a rich or diet with more varied foods.
And so,
um,
this is a case where you have an entire country testing Gary's hypothesis and
finding that basically the opposite of what his hypothesis predicts.
Yeah.
Uh,
let's go with the,
when he was refuting the studies and you want to go,
but this was a level of this course I didn't really want to get into because
that's the study that I'm going to have to read and he's right.
I'm going to read it to try and figure out what the problem is.
I remember looking at that study and thinking there wasn't the kind of data
you're citing.
Maybe there's multiple studies put together,
but the one study I looked at,
the kind of data you're citing wasn't in there.
That this is again a preferences are on my website.
So have at it.
No I will but we'll be off the air by then.
Um,
the beginning of his,
when he started talking it was referencing some studies and you had a problem
with that.
Well they did this whole,
it's a game.
People plan again.
It's why basically in my book I try not to get into,
he said she said studies cause you never know how well they did.
I think we both agree that there's a reproducibility crisis in science.
Some huge proportion of the studies are just wrong.
Whether their experiments or observations,
people sometimes aren't very good at what they do.
And so anyone in either business,
you have to,
Steven likes to say,
I have no evidence,
Stephan dammit.
But simultaneously people accuse me of writing a 600 page book with 150 pages of
references that was too long to read.
So there's clearly evidence this observation in this hypothesis.
My issue with Stephen
is that he speaks as though he knows what this authority.
And so again,
I would like to just read a little bit from your book because as I was prepping
was for you do that though.
The,
he was referencing steady Cuban situation.
I don't know what the reality is.
Before that,
when,
when you first started talking,
he was referencing things that you are stating that he was saying.
What were you saying?
That uh,
the,
the organization that supports him actually refuted.
So that was jam health study.
Yes.
The,
uh,
the new studies.
And now we're talking about the nuisance today on the first two of which,
and we can get,
we can get into detail on this,
on how those refuted Gary's,
uh,
beliefs.
And I would say Gary is about the only person who thinks that they did not
refute his beliefs.
The scientific community is pretty unanimous and respond,
but,
but could you please say what was,
what would the study stayed them yet?
Gary,
let me do it before he did.
The first study is
as a pilot study that,
uh,
depends what you look at to depend whether or not it refuted your beliefs.
So there again,
you have to understand this world.
There are researchers who believe one thing,
Kevin Hall at Nih tends to believe that obesity is an energy balance problem and
people get fat because I ate too much.
I hope I'm doing Kevin Justice.
Um,
and then there's David Ludwig and his colleagues at Harvard who tend to believe
what I believe and we funded them both to do studies and Kevin Hall study.
Uh,
if you believe what Kevin Re,
if you believe Kevin interpreted it correctly,
uh,
was not supportive of this model,
that carbohydrates are ultimately driving insulin and insulin is driving up fat
accumulation.
And then the David Ludwig study,
uh,
reported the opposite and,
and David has criticized Kevin Study and Kevin has criticized David study and
this,
it's the nature of science.
This is what you're doing.
Science.
You're doing an experiment.
People critique it.
Ideally you do another one.
Kevin has decided while Kevin is doing another one,
I think he's asking the wrong questions,
but what I just saw the other day that he's doing another experiment.
Um,
today the middle study was a tree living diet study where,
uh,
done by Christopher Gardner at Stanford University.
And the idea was a original idea was 600 people randomized to either a very low
carbohydrate diet or a very low fat diet.
And we funded it in part because we hoped that Christopher would be able to get
people to almost a ketogenic diet on that low carb side.
And Dean Ornish who promotes a low fat diet always complained that the low fat
diet wasn't fat enough.
So hopefully they'd be able to separate out these two.
Um,
at the end of the trial,
they got pretty lousy adherence.
A low carb was about 25 to 28% carb,
which is by no means a low integrated,
pretty typical in free living.
Studies in the low fat was about equal.
Um,
what they did,
which it's funny,
we realize this on one side,
but not the other.
Um,
they told the low carb group not to eat sugars and refined grains,
which are by my hypothesis,
the most fattening carbohydrates.
And they also told the low fat group to naughty refined sugars and refined
grains.
So they basically removed the most fattening parts of the Diet from both arms of
the study.
It's funny,
we knew that we're going to do it with the low carb group cause you have to,
and my colleagues actually knew they were going to do it with the low fat group.
I didn't know that.
When I found out,
I was stunned because now you're testing two diets.
Neither one of them have sugar or white bread.
So now you see similar weight loss with relatively poor compliance.
Why would they do that?
That doesn't make any sense with the,
uh,
well their argument and we,
we talked to Chris for a lot of his argument.
He was afraid there were two things on,
he wanted to die to be healthy.
Okay.
So a healthy diet in 2015 has become a diet that doesn't have sugar and white
bread in it.
So he wasn't going to promote sugar and white bread to one died or they know,
um,
I take some long as the period of time where they're studying these people.
They were on the die.
They were supposed to be on the Diet for a year.
Okay,
that makes sense then.
Yeah.
So that's the question is again,
would you expect to see a difference?
I can send you an email I wrote to my new see colleagues in 2015 I could read it
when I found out about this low fat thing saying this is insane.
He's removed the,
the,
they're both groups are carbohydrate restricted.
So you could think of it as a low fat carbohydrate restricted diet and a high
fat carbohydrate restricted diet.
And then he kind of got the same answer,
which could be for any reason whatsoever.
There's a paper,
uh,
I don't know if I can,
well,
I'm not going to talk about,
it's bad enough talking about ambiguous studies that have been published without
getting into on publish research.
But so people see this,
the New York Times,
for instance,
the two stories on it,
one of them said it's not about calories,
it's about the quality,
the sugar.
And they're fine grain because both groups restricted sugar and refined grains
and lost weight.
The other and that was written by a reporter who tends to believe what we
believe.
And the other article said,
it's all about the calories because both groups ended up on average eating 500
calories each at the end up.
From a scientific perspective being a poorly done study,
even though we funded it,
I'm not,
it's just,
it didn't answer the question.
You said 500 calories each fight and your carriage calories calorie,
that's actually self reported.
So it's not,
it's not particularly meaningful.
So again,
these are,
I don't like using,
it's a complicated study because it's low in sugar.
Well I want to tell us a free living.
Yeah,
so both sides are low in sugar.
Both sides are not eating processed.
They were two full differences in total carbohydrate intake.
Okay.
So even though they were both not eating as much refined carbohydrate,
they were still two full differences or greater over the period of that study in
total carbohydrate intake.
If you believed.
Now,
frequency questionnaires that you just said,
we don't know whether we have a way you could be talking about vegetables,
you could be talking about fruits.
Well,
these are healthy carbohydrates that they had primarily in this study.
Now we agree that that study can be interpreted from virtually any way you want
it,
especially because it was a free 11.
Definitely don't agree with that.
Um,
now,
now what we will agree on,
I'll agree with you on this,
is that refined carbohydrates and sugar are the most fattening type of
carbohydrate that we can agree on.
My God,
we came to an agreement.
But the question then the question is why is it because people eat too much of,
here's the thing.
If you,
if you believe Gary's hypothesis now,
any kind of carbohydrate increases insulin levels.
Some do it more than others are fine carbohydrates do it more.
Any kind of carbohydrate increases insulin levels relative to fat.
Okay?
And so if that is true and these groups and that matters for fat loss,
these groups had to fold differences in carbohydrate intake,
even though it was predominantly healthy carbs,
you would,
should a seen something,
you shouldn't have seen the exact same amount of weight loss in these two
groups,
right?
Right.
But they're not high in sugar.
Your argument is always,
well that's the other part of the argument,
which is you take away the sugar and that was the problem with one of the
problems with the attic.
Yeah.
The argument I make in and stuff,
it's completely right and I'm defending my hypothesis.
Okay,
I see a study that that he does the same thing.
He did it here.
We all do it.
Do you see a study that disagrees with you?
You find the reason why to not believe it in every study ever done has plenty of
reasons not to do and not to believe it.
That's why independent replication is something you always wanted to get another
group to do the study.
Ideally a third group,
people come in,
they criticize the study,
then you do it again and again and again.
And so you know what I was trying,
when we,
even when we started the nutrition science initiative,
that choice that was a nonprofit,
the choice of the word initiative was to get nutrition researchers to an effect
s stop using these garbage,
poorly designed studies to come to conclusions because they like or dislike the
interpretation,
but try to get them to think the way harder scientists would and developing
studies that ask precisely the right question.
And then so even the pilot study that was interpreted as not supporting this
hypothesis,
and again,
you could argue that for an hour and nobody's going to care.
That study was not randomized.
So a non randomized study,
you can't infer causality.
It's that's why it was a pilot study.
One of the many reasons it was a pilot study of the people who think this
carbohydrate model.
So when we talk about the carbohydrate insulin model,
it means carbohydrates are fattening.
That's the basis of it.
Bread,
pasta,
potato and sugar may be the thing that's necessary to add to the Diet to make
all these carbs fattening.
Cause sugar.
As we talked about this a year and a half ago,
the fructose molecule is metabolized in the liver.
It's linked to fat accumulation in the liver,
which is linked to insulin.
I like the way you're squeezing your stomach fat.
What we're talking about that I got to work out,
dude.
Um,
the uh,
just bored,
you know,
for these experiments to be done right there,
they have to be tested right and he can't use poor.
It's poorly designed experiments of poorly,
you know,
in every experiment ever done.
And so what we've tried to do is keep working towards better experiments.
There's now a new version of the Ludwick experiment being done at the Arnold
Foundation.
Lauren John Arnold funded to the tune of I think $13 million and whatever that
study finds Kevin Hall,
we'll probably find the reason,
look in it and find a reason to question it.
And ideally they would be working together so that you come up with the
criticisms before you've spent $13 million.
But this is how science works.
My job was to tell a good story is Stephanie would say,
and I believe people who read the books can judge whether they're good enough.
Am I convincing in arguing that you add sugar to counter evidence to everything?
There wasn't counter evidence wouldn't require a journalist to come along in 20
whatever it is,
19 lip to make these arguments ask you this because this is something that
you've admitted to something you said rather.
Why are sugary carbohydrates the most fattening?
Well,
if this hypothesis is correct,
I think you would say that they trigger food reward or they are,
wait,
let me just finish on it.
I would say the counter argument is that they create a hormone,
a million in the body that that over response to insulin and insulin.
What we have in said is if you look in a textbook for fat metabolism and fatty,
yet you know what causes fat storage?
Insulin is the hormone that primarily regulates fat storage in your fat cells.
So the idea is you raise insulin and the sugar because of this half of it being
fructose and that mostly being metabolized in the small intestine in the liver
seems may indeed cause insulin resistance.
And if it does you over respondents.
And so one is a peripheral explanation,
not that people don't love it and they don't want to,
you know,
over consume it,
whatever that means.
And the other is a central explanation.
Yeah.
So I mean sugar is a factor that makes us want to eat foods,
right?
I mean this is one of the many food properties I would love to talk about this
more.
That caused dopamine release in the brain.
And dopamine is a chemical that sets our motivational levels to do certain
behaviors.
So the reason we become addicted to drugs is that they go in the brain and they
stimulate dopamine release and that reinforces drug seeking behaviors.
Right?
But this is just causing you to consume more.
Correct.
But you're saying that the actual amount,
let's say if you have the same amount of carbohydrates that are sugary
carbohydrates versus the same amount that our vegetable,
carbohydrates,
sugary carbohydrates are going to be more fattening?
No,
no,
I didn't say it was independently of calories.
It's still entirely dependent on calories.
Yeah,
correct.
And we have randomized controlled trials,
um,
demonstrating this.
So if you look at the randomized there,
by the way,
we're not,
we're not operating in an evidence vacuum.
There's tons of randomized controlled trials and sugar.
These random,
these randomized controlled studies,
are they short term?
Um,
it depends.
Well,
it depends on how you define short term.
They're not lasting years and years and years isn't the issue though.
Longterm chronic effects like that seems to be possibly,
but let me put it this way.
You know,
if you believe that insulin is the,
cause,
the effect of insulin on fat cells happens almost immediately.
So Insulin,
I'm not aware of any mechanism of insulin on fat cells that takes more than a
few hours to occur.
And so if you believe that insulin causes obesity,
this should be happening immediately.
You shouldn't have to wait months and months for this to occur.
No,
that doesn't make any sense at all.
it does make sense.
That makes sense.
It makes sense.
You eat,
you eat carbohydrates sense to you.
Well,
because again,
he's,
he's kind of making this up as he goes along.
So the idea is
we'll explain why it doesn't make sense without insulting.
That's possible.
Has he not been insulting me ever?
I might just biased.
Uh,
I realized that I,
it's everything was perspective but necessarily saying he's insulting your
stories,
not you personally,
but what,
what,
what do you,
why doesn't it make sense to,
okay.
So the idea is
when you're in someone's elevated,
you're storing fat,
right?
Uh,
it depends on what you mean by that.
That's not,
see you do a little bit of Bait and switch here.
That's an end to just answer the question.
If it's a clarify.
Well,
it depends on what do you mean by store?
I mean,
your fat cells are accumulating fat.
When insulin is elevated,
you mean accumulate?
Like,
like w next day you'll have to fat.
It inhibits,
uh,
yeah,
that's incorrect.
It stimulates light bulb protein lipase and it inhibits hormone incentives.
We should,
we should talk about this because that's incorrect.
It's in the textbooks.
No.
Yeah,
we'll talk about what's in the textbook.
Don't worry Gary.
They,
Jesus.
Um,
okay so you don't believe it but just give me your position and I'll let him
refute it.
I it's here but just say it.
Just want to show it.
Okay.
Cause again,
you're going to say it's not in here.
So I have the same textbook and then we'll let Joe here.
Suppression of Fat Mobilization by Insulin and there's another graph that is a
stimulation of fat mobilization.
Congratulations to all of you people that are listening to this [inaudible]
hanging in there.
I know we're in the weeds scientific.
Let me just say this is going to take a long time.
So we agree on the molecular mechanisms.
Okay.
We agree on the molecular mechanisms,
the impact of insulin on enzymes and fat cells.
What we disagree about is the implications of that.
And I think that's what we should talk about because nowhere in that textbook
does it say that insulin regulates the total size of body fat stores like that.
That is something that you both have added onto that mechanism.
Would you like to now a conversation I had with the author of,
no,
not right now actually.
So,
um,
the now the,
let me tell you about the conversation.
Actually,
let me,
I should explain.
We talked for three hours.
Can you stop interrupting me please?
Okay,
now,
um,
let me explain.
So insulin essentially does have effects on enzymes that cause fat cells to take
up more fat and to release less fat.
So that's the part that you're right about.
That's what that textbook talks about right now that does not mean,
that does not imply that insulin causes fat storage as in the accumulation of
fat from day to day.
And let me explain why that is.
So insulin is basically a traffic cop that allows your body to burn the fuel
that you just consumed.
So when you eat a diet that's high in carbohydrate and low in fat,
your insulin goes up,
your body restricts the fat from going out of fat cells.
It turns that down,
not off but down.
It causes less fat to come out of your fat cells and then your body's burning
carbs.
That's what you just state right now.
If you eat a diet that's high in fat and lower in carbohydrate,
you secrete less insulin.
Those effects don't occur on your fat cells and that allows your body to burn
the fat that you just ate.
But at the end of the day,
the amount of fat that you have in your body is the amount that you,
eight minus the amount that you burned.
That's what the terms,
the amount,
this is just arithmetic,
right amount that you eight minus the amount that you burned.
And if you eat a low fat diet,
you're not eating much and you're not burning much.
You're in the same place as if you're eating a diet where you're eating a lot of
fat,
um,
and burning a lot of fat.
And the way we know that's true is because varying the amount of carbohydrate
and fat in the Diet makes no difference to buy.